Good morning Hank, it's monday April the thirtieth. A lot of people wanted to say hi to you this weekend,
so I let him. Hey there Hank, this time I'm not hanging from a fire escape being chased by the police
so this is really an improvement.
Hi Hank, how are you?
Say hi. Hi. Good morning Hank. Good morning Hank. Hi Hank. Good morning Hank.
Now that my editor and a bunch of other authors have said hello to you.
I have a surprise. Good morning Hank and good morning Kelly. This is Francesca. Hi. Have a really good day.
Hey, that was Francesca Lia Block, the
author of Weetzie Bat. The book that I know you like
and I know I like and I also know the Brotherhood 2.0 viewer Kelly likes.
Speaking of Francesca Lia Block, Judy Blume might have just been knocked out
of my guilt free three. And now for our
final introduction. Hi Hank I think you're
really cute and I know you've married already. Hank, as you mentioned in your video last week,
it was totally massively illegal
for me to try to record the Los Angeles
Times Book Prizes on video, so I had to do it really surreptitiously. And as you
can see, I did a really wonderful job
with the camera work. I don't like to
brag but if they give out a Los Angeles
Times Book Prize for the best bootleg
recording of the Los Angeles Times Book Prizes,
I am definitely going to win. So first
Jackie Woodson, the presenter, introduced
each of the five finalists: The rules of
survival,
Tyrell, the Astonishing life of Octavian
Nothing, An abundance of Katherines and
Just in case. And then came the moment we've all been waiting for, and by we,
I mean the 30 people in the audience who care about young adult literature.
Coe Booth! It's my hope that it will fall into the hands of those kids who really do not see themselves represented in literature often.
And my hope also. Congratulations, Coe. Moving on, Hank, I have a challenge for you.
The Yeti and I have both been singing
the Helen Hunt song pretty much non-stop
for the last five days. I want to give
you a brief sense of what it's like to
be at our house right now. Aren't you nervous about trying to find a house? God, so nervous. (sigh)
(sing) Helen Hunt, Helen Hunt
Anyway Hank, we sing the song constantly. We can't get it out of our heads.
The only problem is that we can't quite
sing it in key because it seems to have
been written in the key of awesome. And so Hank, that brings me my challenge.
I would like to challenge you to make more songs, lots more. But what I need right now
is for you to write a song that will
replace the Helen Hunt song because it's
starting to burn a hole in my head.
Oh hey Hank, by the way do you know it's funnier than dogs in New York? That's right,
dogs in Los Angeles. Look at it Hank, it's a chihuahua that seems to be married to a
nineteenth-century plantation owner.